now the archbishop of canterbury is
today calling for thousands of hectares
of land
owned by the church of england to be
used to build affordable housing he's
also calling for the government to do
more to provide affordable homes too
well i'm delighted to say the archbishop
justin welby joins us now so just tell
us what is the idea behind this report
from the church of england
the report's an independent report
chaired by mr charles alvarez
and the uh who's had lifetime experience
in housing with a very powerful group of
very diverse people
and the vice chair is the bishop of
kensington who uh
in whose areas the gram is grenfell
tower it's an independent report
which has worked for two and a half
years and looks at
the crisis in housing the eight billion
people in inadequate housing the poor
housing
the uh diversity uh
issues that mean that people in uh
black minority ethnic communities have
had worse outcomes in the pandemic and
so on
and it provides great challenges to the
church of england
to the government to individuals and to
landowners it's a
very powerful report setting a vision
for 20 years of housing it's a very
wide-ranging report as well
um a list of things you want the
government to do from increasing housing
benefit to committing to more affordable
homes
how big an impact have benefit cuts had
and would you like to see the 20 pound a
week increase to universal credit
maintained
i think the the report mainly focuses
on the issues around affordable housing
and
the 20-pound benefit is something that
a number of bishops have spoken up in
favor of and certainly when you look at
the demand on food banks and
areas like that we need to try and
strengthen people who are really up
against it
but the issue today is affordable
housing not just available housing
we've tried to set out a vision in the
way that
was set out in the 1940s for health
we know in the health service that the
aim is that health should be delivered
free
at the point of need good health care
free at the point of need
everyone agrees on that it's cross party
it is the objective
there is no equivalent in housing and
uh there is no definition of affordable
housing the minister said that in the
house of lords last week
there is uh a need for
every part of society we talk to the
government or the
report it's not us yet and though i very
much welcome and support the report
it talks to the government but it also
challenges the church and the challenge
to the church is where is your soul
where are your values
do you believe what jesus said that you
love
god with all your heart soul strength
and mind and you love your neighbor as
yourself
because if you do you are going to want
stable
sociable sustainable safe
and secure housing uh right
across society and that's the challenge
to the church to use its land and be a
leader in this area yeah of course so
many of the
issues that people experience with
housing have just been exacerbated
in the last year with lockdowns a
pandemic meaning you're spending more
time
at home of course and you're talking
about the challenge to the church but
this is also clearly
a challenge to government as well do you
feel that you're having to step in
because the government hasn't done
enough
it's not this government uh this is the
housing crisis
goes back at least to the mid-1970s
um and you know kathy come home
uh you'd you'd nerve that film
um ken loach right back in the 60s
talking about poor housing that had an
immense effect at the time
but we have far more people in private
rented accommodation
uh then than we do now
and we have far more people a far higher
proportion of the population in
inadequate housing now
than we did then and so
this isn't a about this government or
its
immediate predecessors it goes right
back through
all parties and we need a national
common vision for housing and that will
be sacrificial
the report calls on the the um
church to be sacrificial not to take its
maximum possible benefit
that is the challenge that i welcome and
support
and i affirm that call and call on the
church to react in that way
and it calls on government and
landowners in the same way
okay um you mentioned grenfell in your
first answer
do you think more needs to be done to
remove dangerous cladding from high
rises
uh absolutely i do and uh
that is one of the keynote
recommendations in the report
uh that the government
the report recommends as i say it's
independent but i support this that the
uh the the government take
responsibility for the cladding
uh they've announced 3.2 billion i think
a couple of weeks ago but that
may well not be enough and then recover
that from developers and other people
okay now i just want to ask you a little
bit about coronavirus because of course
we're all waiting for the prime minister
to announce
the road map out of lockdown i know
there's lots of concern about
the amount of school that children have
been missing
what would you like to see tomorrow
well a rate map is a very important
thing
but it has to be one that we can be
really confident about
so if you know as well as i do that this
last
lockdown has been one of the most
painful for the most
people um i go into a local hospital as
an
assistant chaplain and you see
the exhaustion of the staff the way
they're worn down
we need a road map that will stop us
going up and down and i know the
government is deeply committed to that
the huge
success of the vaccine program uh
speaks to what we can do and
i think it needs to be secure
and that we know it is going to be
delivered so we can all move forward i
mean
the pandemic has stripped the paper off
the cracks which we've covered up
there's a schools crisis because
children have missed a year of education
had a disrupted year not all missed it
thanks to the heroism and the quality of
of the schools um there's a housing
crisis which is
revealed being revealed in its full
extent uh
the health service is desperately tired
there is a huge need for
a clear road map and i'm sure the
government is
working on that and will produce that
are they right to prioritize the
reopening of schools
i'm absolutely sure they're right to
prioritize the opening of the schools
that is probably the most urgent thing
it's been the most urgent thing right
the way through i remember talking to
one of the senior medical advisors last
year he said because
the church of england educates more than
a million children
uh in its schools and he said whatever
you do
do everything you can to keep the
schools going because the damage to
children's
mental health their long-term education
is so
is so serious you mentioned the success
of the vaccine rollout in the uk and i
know that you've previously been quite
critical of countries buying up more
vaccines than they need
at what point do you think the uk should
donate
vaccines to poorer countries so many of
which haven't vaccinated anyone at all
well i'm the the anglican communion of
which
technical senior bishop in the world is
80 million people in 165 countries
and the average anglican is a woman in
their 30s on less than four dollars a
day
probably in an area of conflict or
persecution
so most of my work is is with
the very poor around the world i'm very
pleased that not only has this
government done
very very well on the vaccine program
but it's also leading the world
on the international distribution of
vaccines
and i welcome that warmly i hope that
others
follow that example bill gates has
called for that
um and is himself putting huge sums of
money into this
i hope that uh across europe we do this
as soon as they've sorted out their own
problems
on basic distribution of vaccine and i
hope places like canada and the united
states do that
we keep saying this won't be defeated
anywhere until it's defeated everywhere
and certainly in many parts of the world
they need
massive support with this and we are
doing
very well um it's the first time i've
interviewed you so i have a couple of
other
questions if i may um you said last
summer in the wake of the black lives
matter protest that the church would
very carefully review statues at some of
its major places of worship
canterbury cathedral or westminster
abbey and then you said that some will
have to come down
some names will have to change that was
eight months ago
have you removed any statues with links
to the slave trade and do you think
that's something the church should
continue to look at
i'm really pleased that there have been
very few that needed to be removed that
couldn't
simply be put in a better in putting
context and the context the statue
explained
canterbury thankfully hasn't had to take
anything down i really welcome that
i think in total something like two have
been put in museums or something
uh across the whole country and we're
talking tens of thousands
um so that that's
very very good news but we come
back to uh the underlying issue here
which is
slavery and the legacy of slavery the
impact it had on so many people and so
many parts of the world and still has
on the minority i think populations
through racism in this country
and we have to put resources in
to supporting them and demonstrating
that we are
all equal in this country that there is
an end to injustice race racial
injustice among others
in this country that's part of the
reason for the housing report
i'm talking about modernizing the church
would you like to see a woman
archbishop one day
the church and people in the church be
very relieved to know that i have no
influence on my successor
i'd be delighted i'd be delighted what i
want to see is
um diversity of leadership in which
leadership is anointed by the holy
spirit of god and
in which they love jesus christ and they
love their neighbor and enable
millions of people to discover the love
of christ for them
and then just finally of course the
royal family in the church have a very
strong and historic connection were you
sad to see the news that the duke and
duchess of sussex are going to step back
from royal duties
uh i i i don't comment on
uh on the royal family in public have
anything to say it would be said in
private
okay that is fair enough um archbishop
thank you so much for coming on the
program and talking about a very
important
report into housing such a key issue of
course
for so many people at the minute so
thank you thank you
oh just talking about housing uh the
ministry of housing have sent us this
statement
in response to the archbishop's report
we welcome and encourage the practical
steps that the church is taking to make
more of their land available for
affordable housing
we've delivered over 500 000 new
affordable homes since 2010
we're supporting renters by extending
notice periods and banning bailiff
enforcement of evictions
and we're spending billions of pounds to
remove cladding
so people's homes are safe